hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast developing personalized
cancer neo antigen vaccines presented by
AG net Fredersen chief scientific
officer back to ba da s I am Alexis
Krause of lab rats and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before I begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have tied for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this person presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Frederickson I will now
turn the presentation over to her and
I'm happy to be here and allow you to
hear about practically and what we are
doing in the Casa Neil antigen my scene
space today so if we go to the agenda
for today I'll first give you some
background on cancer vaccines and in
particular on the neo antigens and
before I start telling you about a waxy
bodies cancer vaccine strategy and
importantly in the new antigen vaccine
space we also need to discuss new
antigen protection tools and then I will
end up today and talking about McAvoy's
clinical trial experience and our
future plans so we in mexicali we
working within immunotherapy which we
believe is the next wave of cancer
therapy this is a Cancer Care is based
on these five years and recently there's
been a lot of success within
immunotherapy and this is based mostly
due to the success of the checkpoint
inhibitors but all the vaccines and cell
therapies and others falls within this
category and we believe that cancer
vaccines are the best strategy we do to
stimulate a control and then also truly
specific individualized immune response
so the checkpoint inhibitors has
revealed the importance of the immune
system and its role in fighting cancer
so we have observed over the latest
years that if you provide checkpoint
inhibitors to late stage cancer patients
we can increase the survival rate and in
particularly interesting we can see very
long-term survivors have been treated
with checkpoint inhibitors so the
checkpoint inhibitors in the mechanism
action is to allow the immune system to
continue to work to not inhibiting with
the responses of the immune system in
particular t-cells what was also
observed in the patients that had a
clinical benefit on checkpoint
inhibitors was that these actually had a
high knee or antigen burden and this is
where we come into the world neo
antigens specifically due to mutations
in and in in the cancer cells that are
not present in the healthy tissue of
that particular presence and actually
what was observed was the patients that
had a lot of mutations and there's a
hind
Jean Bodin had the higher possibility to
respond to checkpoint inhibitors than
the patients with less mutations and
though the slow new antigen food this
means that in particular for instance
for colon cancer patients the patients
that had been exposed for heavily
smoking and higher chance of benefiting
four from checkpoint inhibitors because
they had exposed their their lung cells
cancer cells for a lot of mutations
however there are still a lot of modest
survival rates by just providing
checkpoint inhibitors to cancer patients
and looking at the mechanism of action
we know that the checkpoint inhibitor
limits the responses to the already
existing t-cell repertoire in the cancer
patients so it allows the T cells that
are already existing to fight tumors if
they are specific to do to ourselves but
it will not unnecessarily increase the T
cell responses and we will not expand T
cells that are not already present in
the patient it also revealed a very
important role of these mutations or new
antigens as a very big target for the
immune system in cancer patients cancer
immunotherapy so the question then is
how can we best boost the immune
response to is it more effective and
broader new antigen specific T cell
responses when we look at the different
indications cancer indications there are
there generally different number of
mutations in the cancer cells based on
the different indications so new
antigens they are tumor specific
mutations not your Associated self
antigens or self antigens so these are
mutations that we own
find in the cancer cells and for
instance melanoma and lung cancer are
the indications where we do find the
highest number of mutations due to
exposure of UV light and smoking for
instance give the high Invitational
burden in those those indications and
that also correlates with the
indications that shows most promise of
of the checkpoint inhibitors on a
general level so again these new
antigens there are newly arising
mutations that happen in the T cells
that could be really good targets for
the immune system because these are
truly tumor specific and we should not
have tolerance developed to the new Neal
epitope despina and formed by the
mutations in the cancer cell so if you
look closer of the T cell immunity to
infectious diseases and to cancer we do
have a very high successful success of
vaccines are targeted to infectious
diseases so and in the cases where this
is T cell dependent there needs to be a
t cell via t cell receptor and infected
cell with an HLA molecule that is
presenting the epitope from the virus or
the bacteria to the T cell receptor so
this is then the antigen is then in this
case foreign because it's a viral or
bacterial origin and it's recognized by
T cell receptor that's not been
tolerance is actually there patrolling
the body to see if there is any foreign
substances that is invading the body
however in the in the cases where we
have pursued the same principle with
cancer self antigens or tumor associated
antigens we try
the cell that is the same principle but
the HLA molecules presenting the
self-antigens tumor associated antigens
they are not foreign to the immune
system and we have already developed
tolerance so the t-cell receptors with
high specificity to the self antigens
tumor associated antigens will have been
deleted in the fibers and thus very
strong specificity will not we cannot we
cannot really write a strong t-cell
response to self antigens and thus we
have had numerous failures with cancer
like scenes trying to increase human and
the t-cell response to self antigens so
with these new antigens so it's it's
self antigen in principle but it has at
least one mutation from the wild type
sequence to these then new mutated
sequence so in this case we need to
understand if the immune system is able
to observe the difference when a self
antigen expresses slightly changed
epitope and displays this to the t-cell
receptor and this we now know that it
can be also as a very foreign epitope
and these are receptors with high
specificity may be able to recognize
these new epitopes as a strong t-cell
epitopes
dependent on the mutation and depending
on a lot of factors on the origin of the
past self antigen as such so this is
what we pursuing in the cancer new anti
gentleman magazine field we want to
erase an immune response through these
new epitopes
in our cell proteins so that the T cells
our own immune response will recognize
the cancer cells as foreign and attack
the cancer cells so we also lately that
new antigens can be strongly neurogenic
tumor antigens there is a study that was
published in Nature in July by they were
Sahin where they first diagnosed
patients with melanoma and and started
to manufacture new antigens vaccines
that were specific for each individual
patient that requires a lifetime when it
comes to manufacturing because you
really need to manufacture one vaccine
for patient in the waiting period they
picked shared antigens tumor soldiers
antigens and and vaccinated the patients
while they were waiting for the neo
epitope vaccines and you can clearly see
from the results that the immune
responses to the shared antigens were
not as strong to the immune response
that they were able to elicit to the new
attitudes there are higher affinity
t-cell receptors available for new
antigens in circulation and the
interferon gamma t cell responses to the
new antigens can just be stronger than
to the shared tumor associated antigens
so this is a fairly new concept so there
are two clinical studies with
personalized new antigen magazines both
in melanoma patients that were published
in nature in july with six or thirteen
patients with with reclose 200 new
epitopes in both studies tested in these
patients these were either
vaccinated with peptide vaccines or with
RNA based vaccines but the results are
quite promising they did with observe
t-cell responses to between sixty and
seventy five seventy six percent all the
new epitopes that were selected for the
patients and with strong immunity
mythically however it was mostly cd4
t-cells that they were able to race
towards the new antigens and not that
successful cd8 t-cell responses however
as a different patients in an adjuvant
setting so they did not have a high
tumor burden and it's a bit difficult to
speculate about the clinical responses
although it does seem to to be very
promising so far but we're still waiting
studies in cancer patients main stage
cancer patients with with a high tumor
burden I think what we observed in the
study was that more than 50% of the neo
pittosporum eugenic the cancer vaccine
strategy is able to increase the immune
response to the novel a t-cell response
t-cells that already were present
specific to your new antigens in the
patients I was silly enough
approximately one third of the year how
all the new epitopes that were tested
but also raised the noble t-cell
responses to two new antigens that could
not be found in the patients before
vaccination so 2/3 of those rare and
turn right towards the noble and new
epitopes and and also importantly most
of the responses observed where cd4
helper t-cell responses and not the cd8
t-cell responses that we've learned
classically that we want to race in
order to have and strong
response to towards the cancer cells so
what there are a lot of promises to
vaccinating patients with new antigen
based cancer vaccines because we now
know that it might be very effective if
we are able to raise t-cell responses to
these newly mutated tor specific
antigens however what we learned is that
these tumor specific mutations are
practically all the time patient
specific so it is very very rarely that
we can find the same rotation in two
different patients and also that that
mutation is a perfect match with their H
main molecules so what we are actually
pursuing is to make one vaccine
specifically designed per patient that
means that we have to go through these
processes where we first take a biopsy
from the tumor and we also harvest
healthy tissue or blood samples we
sequence them both and we compare so we
can identify the tumor specific mutation
in that particular patient and based on
the invitations and its relationship to
the wine type and different other
features we do a lot of bioinformatics
in order to select the Neo epitopes that
can be promising in the vaccination
setting and then we have to be one to
manufacture the vaccine under GMP and
that will be one magazine per patient
and then the vaccine needs to be shipped
back to the site clinical site
administered and it needs to be
informants and that can elicit strong
immunogenicity and hopefully provide
clinical benefit
so in order to go through this entire
process and specifically define one
unique perfectly fits vaccine patient it
is essential that this can be done
within a reasonable time and reasonable
cost and it very strong efficacy that's
what we are pursuing in Mexico knee so
then I can tell you about practically
and the cancer vaccine strategy that we
using within this space so maximally in
the biotech company we have one clinical
study where we just finalized enrollment
in the face to a this is called the
limit EO one study and it's the mono
therapy where we treat patients that
have developed precancerous circulations
with either pubic HPV 16 cancel Xing and
then we are now and heading into a new
study within the new antigen vaccine
field where we will set up the path keep
studying treating patients with melanoma
lung cancer bladder renal head and neck
that will be initially 40 patients and
the aim is to have the first patient in
within this quarter so max Abadi was
originally developed based on the
concept of targeting antigens to antigen
presenting cells in order to create more
efficacious vaccines so we know that
every antigen needs to be processed and
presented by antigen presenting cells on
HLA molecules to t-cells in order to
elicit the strong t-cell response and we
make sure that this happens effectively
by creating the vaccine in this a
specific format that is created as a DNA
vaccine
plasmid that is encoding three different
modules functional we call functional
modules one is the targeting unit that
targets the engines antigen presenting
cells one its diverse ation unit the
cross links the target receptors and
then we have the antigenic unit so the
the vaccine is actually administered as
a naked DNA plasmid and allows us to
have illegal expression of the protein
format which actually simplifies the
manufacturing process dramatically and
that is very important when you want to
create one magazine with a patient
so the mechanism of action the DNA
plasmid that enclose this waxy body
fusion protein will be delivered
intramuscularly then will enter the
muscle cells and the Muslim cells the
myocytes will produce and secrete the
protein format of the vaccine so we will
protein expression and secretion and
then the targeting unit in our clinical
products is a naturally occurring
inflammatory chemokines and this
chemokine has the ability to target and
attract antigen presenting cells its
natural function is to attract a large
immune system when there is an
inflammation so the antigen presenting
cells will actually travel to the
injection site due to the high
concentration of the waxy body protein
with these chemokines locally and then
the targeting units the chemokine will
bind to the chemokine receptors on the
surface of design John presenting cells
it does so in a dynamic manner and when
it binds these two chemokine receptors
it will cross-linked the receptors and
this provides an activation
maturation signal to the
antigen-presenting cells and then the
entire complex is taken up by receptor
mediated internalization and broken down
and presented on MHC class 1 and MHC
class 2 another interesting feature with
this particular chemokine and its ligand
the chemokine receptor is that they are
described to be particularly good at
entering this cross presentation pathway
and allowing effective presentation of
the new antigens then of the antigens on
a jewel a class 1 and effectively a
stimulating cd8 positive T cells so we
know that the waxy body can can target
dendritic cells we know here that it can
attract the antigen presenting cells so
we can actually in the middle here we
can we can inject the waxy body encoding
and construct encoding and sharing so we
can also the T transfected cells here be
shown as red and they will be
infiltrated by antigen presenting cells
so the this will happen locally and we
will have very strong delivery of the
antigens to the antigen presenting cells
we also can see that the antigen
presenting cells mature upon binding the
waxy body protein and up regulates ETA D
and C D 86 for instance shown in this
slide
another nice feature with the last body
is this local attraction due to the
local attraction of the antigen
presenting cells we deliver can deliver
our magazines with this simple jet
injector is a needle free jet injectors
very small honey easy
use and very minimal pain
this is cost-effective and applicable
for multiple immunizations but the
reason why I bring this up is that
normally DNA vaccines has been shown to
be less immunogenic and also that in
order to have an effective immune
response to the antigens delivered with
a non targeted DNA vaccine you need to
deliver it in combination with in vivo
electroporation which is quite painful
and requires electricity and quite
costly devices and and this can provide
a lot of pain to the patients so that's
an added feature of this attraction of
the antigen presenting cells and we show
that with is targeting unit we can
achieve the same level of efficacy with
this far merchant needle featured
injector instead of using in vivo
electroporation so when it comes to the
new antigens with vast body we have
gained a lot of expertise in preclinical
studies testing a different number of
new epitopes different lengths on the
orbitals different order and different
linkers of the new epitopes
in order to find the optimal robust
racing forward that we can move into the
clinic so this stage we tested more than
70 different VVT new constructs with
more than 3 400 narratives to date and
that gives us a lot of comfort
moving into the clinic and we found the
optimal format we will roll into the
clinic with the format where we can have
10 between 10 and 20 different neo ecwid
holes in one magazine and all new york
returns will then be from the same
cancer patient so have multiple targets
in one patient but the manufacturer
is just one magazine per patient so we
tested the format and we we have a lot
of expensive experience with the
performance knowing that it can provide
both rapid strong and long-lasting
immune responses compared to non
targeted vaccine delivery with the new
epitopes we use the information in the
literature where where new epitopes have
been already described for a few mouse
tumor models P 16 in this case and
complete delivery of the exact same neo
epitopes in a vaccine body format give
it a meal head-to-head will giving the
exact same peptides the same sequence in
combination with a poly IC adjoint two
different doses and we could confirm
that the response immune responses to
linear epitopes the both stronger and
broader with the last for the
vaccination delivery system than with
peptides and add joins interestingly we
also observe that it was not necessarily
the same new epitope that dominated
amongst attorney orbitals if you keep
them as a peptide as if you give them in
the voxi body forward so if you see that
the epitope number 9 p m9 the purple one
is the strongest one if you give it a
peptide but with the flexibility peptide
number 10 is a very strong epic of this
is not immuno genic at all if you give
it a step 5
so recently we looked deeper into
exactly the background for the
differences in this
so the immune response to the same ten
me of the tops if you give them with
peptidyl for the IC adjuvant or as an
RNA vector has been published and before
and even though they were all originally
pitched based on bioinformatics and show
that these could be potentially strong
and b12 binding to MHC class 1 and thus
eliciting cd8 t-cell responses most of
the t-cell responses observed is to ward
these 10 epitopes if you give them a
spectral RNA for cd4 t-cell responses
also and the response the immune
response profile if you gave them a
peptide of RNA these are published in
the same papers seem to be quite
identical but not really fully
overlapping and then when you deliver
exactly the same new epitopes in the
waxy body with an informant we observed
a completely different picture so we did
actually observe a very strong cd8
t-cell response to more than 60% of the
neo epitopes in this case and we also
the cd4 t-cell response to all ten new
epitopes
so it was broader but it was also more
cd8 t-cell responses in this case and we
interestingly enough to all the new
every toes but we observe the cd8 t-cell
response we could also see cd4 t
substance and it was quite different
from the RNA and peptide published data
we look in the next slide it's the same
data when you can actually really see
the differences in the immune response
it's almost opposite so if you look at
peptide M 2 & 3 & 4 & 7 & M
these are the ones where we also a very
strong cd8 t-cell response combined with
the cd4 T cell response and those are
the epitopes that are the weakest either
non responding or very weakly responding
if you give the exact same sequence
instead as a peptide Foley I see vaccine
impacts informant so it really shows
that the the vaccination the vaccination
system is extremely important to elicit
the right t-cell response to the exact
same antigen and then even though we are
able to predict a very strong cd8 t-cell
epitopes it cannot be immunogenic if you
do not deliver it in the optimal
vaccination moment another thing we've
looked into is the number of new
epitopes and the importance of having a
technology where you can elicit where
you can insert multiple new epitopes in
one vaccine so we try in a system where
we had 10 year pickles and the other way
we had 20 Nia pickups shown in red and
blue here so we um we challenged mine
three tumor cells and then we measured
the tumor growth and we vaccinated my
span with construct packs for the
constructs either holding Tony abri
stalks of twenty near epitopes and we
could really see that there was a huge
benefit of using multiple new epitopes
and the breadth of the immune response
can be important and we believe this is
even more important moving into the
clinic and taking into consideration the
heterogeneity of the tumor the different
metastasis so it's also a huge advantage
to her
technology that can hold multiple new
epitopes in one construct when you have
to manufacture one vaccine for patient
in contrast to peptide vaccines for
instance where each peptide is
manufactured individually moving into
the new nitrogen prediction tools I
think the data just show that it's very
different immune response to the exact
same new antigen when you deliver it as
a peptide are they of active polity in a
vaccine that led us into trying to
develop our own new epitope prediction
tool based on data in vivo data where we
use our own delivery vehicle in mice and
looking into the immune response to each
individual neo epitope and looking into
then all the features of the new
epitopes that are strongly imagining
weakly energetic and all intergenic and
training the selection tool based on the
data that we achieve vaccinating with
our own delivery activity delivery
device we've done this now with close to
400 new epitopes and started to see a
very strong pattern and this is the
pattern this is the selection tool that
we will be using rolling into the clinic
we recently tested our a near the top
prediction to the latest version on a
completely uncracked rised to a model
PLL to lung cancer tumor model and in
this case we were able to find 68%
immunogenic near epitopes with a very
strong total immune response so we very
confident moving into the clinic with
this prediction - based on our own data
so we're done
moving into the clinic we now received a
conditional approval to start our Vienna
one trial so we plan to recruit the
first patient here in he 1 2018
importantly for for Rexy body our
previous program with the therapeutic
HPV vaccine has given us a lot of
benefit moving into the clinic with the
new antigen based cancer vaccines it's
actually the exact same construct that
we will be using since the DNA plasmid
same path plasmid backbone same
targeting unit the chemokine same
dimerization unit the only difference is
the antigenic unit which in this study
was to fulling proteins from HPV 16
while in a new entrant studies this will
be new epitopes that will be specific
and different than from for each
individual patient so i actually and
everything that each individual patient
in the new antigen trial will receive
those components will already have been
tested in the patients in our HPV trial
so this study we learned that we did not
observe any drug related SAEs so as a
monotherapy
the maximal a vaccine is very safe
we tested actually two different dosing
regimens in our study so we learned the
importance of having a quite tight
vaccination interval three week
intervals induce the strongest immune
response so we will move that forward
into the new our children study and we
did also observed a very promising
clinical efficacy that strongly
correlated relative
responses in this study so we have
information both on safety if it give me
those those regimented combination
strategies manufacturing experience from
the study and with the advantage from
when we move into the next maybe and one
faster
so this study is an open-label first
human dose to relish safety feasibility
and efficacy on multiple dosing with a
potential new meta therapy it will be
performed in patients with locally
advanced or metastatic melanoma
non-small cell lung cancer t renal cell
carcinoma your CV cancer and spoil
yourself carcinoma of the head and neck
these are all indications that have
approved checkpoint inhibitor is a
standard of care and they will have a
moderate to high Invitational load so in
this study in order to learn as much as
possible of the contribution of the
backseat body vaccine but also take
advantage follow the synergistic
responses all paxton vaccination and
checkpoint inhibitors we will enroll
patients has been treated with
checkpoint inhibitors for at least 12
weeks and then start manufacturing the
eternia vaccine and in this case we will
enroll asians then then have not
received a complete response of
checkpoint inhibitors and they're also
not rapid professors but the
intermediate responders and then we will
add vaccines and i will be a few months
before between they started checkpoint
inhibitors therapy and when they start
they leave it in your vaccinations which
hopefully will allow us to dedicate the
you respond technical responses as well
more smooth more likely to be due to the
vaccine
the only detect where individuals we are
working with very happy to be working
with these really renowned international
clinical sites in Germany work with you
can browse in Heidelberg in Germany
Angela crocodile occurred in unique and
professor fkd again in Frankfurt there
will have a lot of experience with
immunotherapy trials we checkpoint him
with the therapy and also have a special
interest with within neo antigens so
going back to this line our with the
processes that we will go through for
each patient
Rexie body has been developed its own
new dividend yield specific proprietary
selection method that we believe will be
the key in order to find the most
energetic new epitopes compatible with
our vaccination principle and then again
importantly what they observe is that
this vaccination technology can increase
the likelihood of engaging cd8 t-cell
responses to the needy epitopes for the
manufacturing we do deliver the pivotal
new vaccines as naked DNA plasmid in PBS
it's a very rapid growers cost-effective
manufacturing DNA plasmids are stable
and safe and the format allows us to
haul up to 20 neo bit obsolete per
vaccine which means that the vaccine
manufacturing process is this
cost-effective and then when it comes to
the delivery we have the needle free
delivery patient friendly and the
mechanism of action of the racket
for was a very roughly strong
long-lasting response we also see that
it's broad and cd8 dominated so we
believe we can fulfil the requirements
so having a rapid cost effective and
efficacious vaccines moving into this
new exciting field so this is the core
team in Mexico T of the headquarters
here in Oslo in Norway really looking
forward into starting the clinical trial
and see how this pans out and in
patients so thank you for listening in
and then I'll take any questions from
now thank you dr. Frederickson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask question drop down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is manufacturing of one vaccine
per patient seems challenging both from
a logistical and cost perspective which
steps do you consider as key factors to
bring individualized medial antigen
based campus or vaccines to the market
yeah so I absolutely this this can be
quite challenging and bringing it to the
market I think it's extremely important
that you have this technology that once
can hold a number of new epitopes in the
same vaccine so we don't have to
manufacture multiple vaccines per
patient it's also important to have a
robust
ecology and manufacturing DNA plasmids
should-should love this to happen also
in a robust and rapid many manufacturing
technology and this stage I think there
are multiple steps so that we can
optimize and want one of the features
you can do is to put everything in one
dedicated facility so you have all the
steps from sequencing to miracle
prediction and manufacturing and release
under the same roof and that is
something that will happen in the future
and will shorten the time period as well
but I think the key is to have a
magazine nation technology in technology
that allows a robust rapid manufacturing
as DNA plasmids our next question is DNA
plasmids are stable and to be easily
manufactured but has shown limited
success as vaccine delivery vehicle how
does the VAX body differ in mode of
action from traditionally DNA plasmids
great question I think it's um multiple
factors here and importantly the normal
DNA plasmid and we know does not have
these targeting unit in relies on direct
inspection of antigen presenting cells
so in in that case you want the DNA
plasmid to transfix an antigen
presenting cells so that the antigen
presenting cells can present the antigen
that is delivered directly on the
surface on MHC molecules that does not
necessarily happen as targeted as you
want you also need to activate the
antigen presenting cells and what we do
with the waxy body technology we make
sure that in principle all the antigens
are delivered to antigen presenting
cells not through the transfection of
the DNA plasmid but the protein format
that is produced and secreted
sure that these ends up in the
antigen-presenting cells both through
the attraction and to the kudu binding
to the surface receptors of the
antigen-presenting cells and also this
important feature that we have but we
ensure that it is a very effective cross
presentation to cd8 t-cell responses so
so it is a different completely
different mode of action which is the
reason why we see a much stronger immune
response is key this technology
activating cd4 and as you show
particularly cd8 t-cell will the neo P
taupe selection for the backs of bodies
to vaccine be the same as used for other
vaccines yeah I just a business back to
the core point I think it's also
something you hear that a new epitope is
not a neo epitope it really depends on
the format that you deliver the neo
epitope in so you know I don't think you
can run rely on the exact same
prediction tool I think this is due to
the fact that you deliver an EOP talk to
different cells different antigen
presenting cells and let the mere we go
with them process and presented
differently and also the distribution or
they receive less one versus every
c-class series of importance here to
give responses so if you have a
technology that can can process them
present a new epitope so I receive just
too too much better than extent and on
empathy trust one you need to find a new
orbital prediction tool that reflects
that part also in the selection process
however as we the like see body where we
observe that we can elicit a very strong
sylia t-cell response to the Neo PTO's
we can poke
is also on predicting the strong cd8
t-cell and epitopes the future would
like to I'd like to once again thank dr.
Frederickson for her presentation I'd
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May of
2018 email from laberd's letting you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye